foreign
[Music]
can I come to your house tonight sure I
don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the Barbies
and planned choreography and a bespoke
song you should stop by so cool
it is the best day ever so was yesterday
and so is tomorrow and every day from
now until forever
you guys ever think about dying
when my heart breaks some things have
been happening that might be related
cold shower falling off my roof and my
heels are on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
what do I have to do you have to go to
the real world
and go back to your regular life or you
can know the truth about the universe
choice is now yours the first one the
high heel you have to want to know okay
do it again
[Music]
I'm coming with you okay
wow this is the real world what's going
on why are these men looking at me yeah
they're also staring at me
[Music]
Barbie in the real world that's
impossible if this got out this could be
an extremely weird thing for our world
this would be
catastrophic we haven't played with
Barbie since we were like five years old
no one rests at stall
back in a box
[Music]
humans only have one ending
tears live forever
[Music]
no I won't let you do just one
appendectomy but I'm a man but not a
doctor can I talk to a doctor you are
talking to a doctor and I need a clicky
pen No a sharp thing no there he is
Doctor somebody get security
[Music]
if you're still in doubt